[Music]
it's to you jack
give me a minute please okay
a room without windows a room without
doors
it's to you jake give me a minute
please
[Laughter]
a room or no guy but i can spy the
tongue
no not gonna risk it this time four
cards please
here's my ace jack now that you're
moving in can i make one small request
what's that
change everything about your personality
i get it
comedy didn't tell me jack was moving in
with you not moving in he's just staying
with me to his apartments finished
oh i know that one i know uh did he need
a stronger
he's not humming your intro okay that's
just a straight guy's way of thinking
that you and i could ever be a couple
okay first of all will should only be so
lucky okay so let's just clear that
right up
second of all you don't even know me
that well why would you just assume that
i was gay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
are you finished okay fyi folks most
people that meet me do not know that i
am gay
jack blind and deaf people know you're
gay
dead people know me
[Music]
can we play poker yes yeah come on who's
in i'm in for 10.
i'm fine grace keep playing oh look it's
sporty spice
did you and danny have a fight yeah but
i i don't want to talk about it right
now i can't even think straight
that's funny neither can jack
grace did you know i was gay when you
met me my dog knew
so the fabrics never came in and i
wasn't able to make the presentation
diamond interiors got the job i'm sorry
what a disappointment
thank you see that's all i wanted to
hear but danny said well when you put
everything off to the last minute
oh yeah and i
lost it i started screaming why can't
you just let me have my feelings
grace that is so barbara deangelis
making love work
i know it wasn't and then he says get
this
you don't have to get hysterical you
sound just like your mother
if you were on jerry springer that's the
minute you jump out of your chair
yeah can you believe that you're staying
here tonight go wash your face i'll make
up your bed
you sound just like your mother what
kind of person says that
kind of person you should have dumped a
year ago what
i said i hear they're re-releasing
vertigo sound just like your mother when
you want to push someone's buttons
that'll do it
hey roomie
jack you you can't move in tonight what
grace is very upset i told her she could
stay here tonight you move in tomorrow
okay that's interesting
you'd think maybe you could have told me
this oh i don't know before i packed up
my entire life
you don't understand grace has had a
really what's in the hat box your tiara
look guapo he made a funny shut up will
i just slept all the way over here from
the east side and you know how much
guapo hates riding a taxi
okay take it easy jack sound just like
your mother
crossing the line okay you nasty bitter
lonely balding man
i don't need this crap from you will you
know what i just don't need it
what time tomorrow
you